al enterarse de que recibiría el premio
Cervantes el poeta venezolano Rafael
cadenas bromeaba diciendo que pensó
podría ser un invento de Don Quijote en
uno de sus extravíos hoy en la ciudad
natal de Miguel de Cervantes es de
invento se ha convertido en realidad
para el donagenario que además de poeta
es ensayista y profesor Los reyes de
España le han entregado el premio más
importante de las letras en lengua
castellana en su discurso de aceptación
y visiblemente nervioso cadenas confesó
que este es un honor que le sobrepasa y
afirmó que está lleno de España primero
por la lengua compartida y segundo por
su literatura tuvo palabras para El
Quijote obra que leyó con tan solo 16
años pero que tomó Nuevo sentido al
releerlo de adulto también advirtió que
la lengua española está maltrecha por la
influencia del inglés el premio
Cervantes 2022 nacido en barquisimeto en
1930 es el quinto poeta consecutivo en
ser premiado pero es la primera vez que
un escritor venezolano
recibe el Cervantes que se lleva
entregando desde
1976 su militancia en el partido
comunista de Venezuela le obligó a
exiliarse en Trinidad durante la
dictadura de Marcos Pérez hasta 1957 y
pese a ser crítico con los gobiernos de
Chávez y maduro ha mantenido su
residencia en Caracas aunque se declara
en ayuno de información sobre la
actualidad política de su país